as we welcome in the head coach of the
national champs Tony Bennett how much
sleep last night coach a little bit but
it's all good there that's all good when
did it hit you I don't know if it quite
as yet but no I think this journey has
been amazing and um you know when the
final horn went off you know after we
had wanted overtime I just sitting on
that stool cuz you're up and they put
you on such a stage for the floor I just
kind of bowed my head and I just said
thank you I was I was overcome with
thankfulness and humbled in a way that I
felt like it you know is so improbably
you know how we want these games and all
the things that went on and I think it
just it dawned on me and you know to see
our former players to see Joe Harris
Malcolm Brogdon there in the locker room
after just to look at the guys we had a
we did a cool thing after that meant the
world to me I think those moments it'll
continue to sink in but it was so good
so good I couldn't help but think your
father having been able to broadcast one
of your games when you played and having
met your father and I still tell people
the practices were probably pretty
boring to the players but so clinical
and I just see so much of what you're
doing now and what your father probably
gave you and for him to be there and
enjoy that what was the moment like when
you saw dad afterwards know that was
special I got he hardly comes to any
games he battles his nerves so much I
think haven't been in a coaching
profession it's hard but he came to the
sweet 16 he lead eight games that was
maybe the third game he'd been to and
probably I don't know few years and then
for him to not come to the final four
game but the championship I was I was
glad he was there to see it because I
think it was like you said I heard you
say it was really a high level game and
a lot of people thought it's gonna be so
low scoring but ironically you know it
wasn't quite that way but it was teams
answering each other and as I said his
fingerprints are all over my coaching
and I watched him and do it with you
know maybe less talent and take programs
beyond so it was really good that was
the game you mentioned was that one of
your first years of broadcasting it was
1991 or 92 I was a senior and we did the
but it was Bubba versus
they and I know was that we thought what
are your first teams doing that yes I
recall that a long time ago and I
remember that you didn't play much
defense back there Tony no you could
score that's why I'm always curious when
his scores trying to teach defense
because you guys are known for your
defense
we're talking to Tony Bennett and he's
the head coach of Virginia if I would
have told you a year ago after the loss
to UMBC hey your win in the national
title next year you would have said what
I would have smiled at you and said
that's you know you're just trying to
make me feel better because I feel like
crap right now that's the honest answer
but uh but I knew that it was going to
be um it's gonna be a year that was
going to be probably so important in all
of our lives because of what we're gonna
have to face and go through together and
absolutely knew I was we're gonna need
to rely on each other and it did some it
did some unique bonding and boy built
resilience and these guys in a way that
I don't know what else could have some a
sports standpoint I'd like to clarify
that it this is a game and this is
sports it's not life because there's so
many worse things but I do think it's a
good message of like we said hope and
resiliency and guys coming together I
can't think of a much better story in
sports like you know for us at least
what about bonding in the offseason so
you have the devastating loss and then
what do you do to as a coach to kind of
hit the reset button in the offseason
with these kids yeah actually it was
pretty cool everything was pretty
intentional and you know obviously we um
once we started our workouts I decided
to UM to go on a whitewater rafting trip
just because we said it's a blast and
it's fun and and we did it we had a good
time but that the story look short of it
is went whitewater rafting and I I
talked to the guys about it um why we
were doing it and we I remember floating
down the river you know looking up but
just saying to myself Lord what is this
year have in store for us so when we get
to Minneapolis for the Final Four they
gave us right when I got off the
airplane they for some reason again was
because the land
10,000 lakes they give each player in me
a paddle and it says the road ends here
and the first thing we did as a team was
go whitewater rafting kind of as a a
real strong team by anything besides you
know the means and you know is all about
the you know paddling together being in
the boat the oars I thought it was
really uh it was it was kind of a neat
irony the way it started and then the
way it kind of ended getting to the
Final Four at any moment in this
tournament did you think it was going to
come crashing down well yeah and I guess
to be honest like I had made peace with
whatever the outcome would be all year
and I know this will sound strange but
if it meant I wasn't sure if I wanted to
be initially another another number one
seed one the fact that these guys
stepped up and won a share of the ACC
and battle and then you know as you're
getting close and like alright we're
probably going to be a 1 seed and with
that comes unique pressures even if you
haven't lost that game but when you've
lost being the only team in the history
of the game and then you got to step
into that moment again it's a pressure
unlike anything a team is of course ever
experienced and then to add to that when
we were down 14 I thought that moment it
was it was a bit much but I remember
telling her guys at halftime listen you
can't panic but you got a fight like
crazy and I think being in that moment
and seeing those guys like you know show
the resiliency and the poise to win the
gardner-webb game I think that and
that's what I told them before the
championship game I said you know you
handled things and I said you were built
for this because the pressures you've
faced and overcome I think that in a
powerful way let us handle any of these
things but as I said sorry for the long
answer I made peace with hey if we were
going to lose in the first round again
or if we weren't going to get advanced I
was ok with it I wouldn't have been good
again but I know I could have handled it
but I was just holding it with open
hands now I know that you're in the game
in the moment we're watching the game
and your poor life I mean I I don't know
what you're going to do for her or take
her someplace but Tony she was every
moment she was grinding she's grinding
more than you were
that's awesome dashi she's actually one
of it Coleman's most peaceful people I
know so I'll be curious oh I like me
whatever you want she's got it
Congrats enjoy and please tell your
father I said allo thank you Tony
that's Tony Bennett content old Tiger
Coach's Corner proud to be the exclusive
tire the Dan Patrick show no matter
where you drive what you drive how you
drive
continental designs tires for what you
do for more information visit Kahn
dental tire calm Continental Tire for
what you do yeah he was referencing a
game that I did I believe what George
McGinnis the former great ABA player and
George was my color commentator and we
did a game at Butler Fieldhouse
so it's Butler against Wisconsin Green
Bay and Tony hit the game-winning shot
hit a three and he was a really good
player drafted by the Hornets but his
father was such a clinical type coach
like everything they were they were
practicing pick-and-rolls
and in and it's you know a veteran team
in it I was thinking oh my god this
would drive me crazy but he left nothing
to chance
and you were practicing the same things
over and over and over and you know you
went on to Wisconsin but a brilliant
coach great coach and congrats to Tony
but you know it's got to be a fun night
where you're watching your son win a
national championship having a hard time
watching your son win a national
championship at that forum or Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]